well you got to feel sorry for this
generation of kids for many reasons
really but especially because
this is the first generation of children
who will know what it's like to be
raised by social media influencers
they're the first to experience the
trauma
of having their childhoods mind for
tick-tock content so take for example
the four-year-old daughter of tik-tok
influencer cat calamani whose social
rejection by the neighborhood kids was
immediately converted into content by
mommy
kat has made somehow headlines this week
after issuing a to use the new york post
phrase heartfelt plea to other parents
on the platform the post reports how a
tearful and devastated mother witnessed
her child being bullied and and
responded how any loving parent would by
leveraging the incident for internet
clout
so here is the emotional video which has
garnered over two million views by the
way which was totally not the point i'm
sure it was not the point of getting
views but uh here it is
parent and have kids
i need your help why is parenting so
hard my daughter's four and has these
little girls around her neighborhood who
i thought she got along great with well
i looked out the window and i saw
a couple of the girls putting their
hands out like they didn't want to play
with her and so i walked over there and
they were telling she's not allowed to
play with them because they didn't want
her to
she was devastated she was crying and
asking me why her friends don't like her
and why she can't play with them i
didn't even know how to respond i just
said
everyone sometimes makes mistakes and
sometimes people
aren't feeling the best and then they
treat other people not so nicely and you
can't control that
and when you are around people who are
not so nice it's just best to walk away
because you can't control them
how do you handle situations like this
with your children
well not like that
she didn't know how to respond
she didn't know how so instead she took
out her phone
shot a selfie video
then edited it
and put sad piano music in the
background and then posted it and then
started furiously responding to the
supportive comments all while her
daughter presumably stood by sobbing
having now been ignored by both her
friends and her mom
but it's really it's the music which
does it for me that's that's what does
it it's you you that's what destroys any
chance that this was like an authentic
i'm reaching out for help you're taking
the time to pick out the emotional music
to go along with it
no let me ask you something what if
there was uh someone out there who kept
a log of every single thing you did
every minute of the day i think that
would be pretty creepy if that was the
case well what if i told you that's
exactly what happens every time you go
online your internet provider like at t
or comcast is allowed to store logs of
every website you've ever visited and
they can legally sell this data to
anybody they want that's why i always
use expressvpn expressvpn reroutes your
internet connection through their secure
server so your internet providers can't
see or log what you do online now many
of you might be wondering well if i'm
routing all my data through a vpn then
doesn't that mean that the vpn can see
what i'm doing and they can log my data
instead very astute well here's what
i'll tell you you're right to think that
way many vpns claim to have a no logs
policy but they've been caught logging
customer activity anyway expressvpn is
the only vpn i trust because they use
trusted server technology and you don't
have to take my word for it or express
vpn's word for it expressvpn is so
confident in their no logs claim they
even had one of the biggest assurance
firms audit their technology stop
letting people keep logs of what you do
online visit expressvpn.com
matt wall show right now and find out
how you can get three months free
now of course even apart from the clout
chasing the problem with the video is
that it's histrionic and absurdly
melodramatic it look it's really not a
big deal at all when little kids tell
other little kids that they don't want
to play with them that's how little kids
are they're quite fickle as a community
okay four-year-olds in particular are
prone to just like casually stabbing
each other in the back for no
discernible reason it's extremely common
for kids that age to play together
nicely for a while only for one to
suddenly run out of the room
and snitch on the other trying to get
him in trouble based on real or imagined
crimes and the amazing thing though is
that they can go right back to being
friends after that the betrayed child
doesn't hold anything against his
betrayer he doesn't even look at the
other kid and say what the hell dude i
thought we were cool what are you doing
no he he knows the rules and he accepts
them they all accept tattletailing as
inevitable it's it's a custom among
their people they all understand this
and the same goes for incidents like
what cat
a child will want nothing to do with
another child one minute only to be
pronouncing her a best friend the next
and in fact girls don't grow out of that
habit until like in their mid-70s
but the point is that kids experience
hurt feelings betrayals rejections all
the time
they'll be utterly devastated for 45
seconds and they forget about it
and you can even shorten that 45 second
period of sadness by giving them candy
or a sticker or a band-aid kids love
band-aids you can heal almost any wound
physical or emotional with a band-aid
and if it's a physical wound the
band-aid doesn't even have to be on the
part of their body that has the wound
the other day my my daughter had a small
cut on her on her hand but insisted that
we put a band-aid on her elbow
again these are the ways of childhood we
can never fully understand it even
though they were once our ways too
does this mean that we should never take
our children's emotions seriously no it
just means that we shouldn't blow things
out of proportion or create drama where
it's not necessary there's no need to
make mountains out of mole hills and we
especially should not be making
tick-tock videos out of them because
that is really the problem here you know
the world has always had mothers who get
far too emotional and upset about the
most minor pains or difficulties their
their children suffer i mean every good
mother has a tendency
in that direction to one degree or
another that's why it's important to
have both a mother and a father in the
home
the mother has enough empathy to
compensate for the father's occasional
deficiencies in that regard and the
father has enough calmness and
rationality to compensate in the other
direction that's the complementary
nature of the sexes
saving the day yet again
but kat's problem is really not an over
abundance of empathy or emotion her
problem if anything is the opposite her
emotion is a performance for the camera
you know she saw her daughter's sadness
as a thing to be exploited a piece of
content for public consumption
she claims in the video that the
incident just happened a moment ago
which means that almost immediately the
thought occurred to her that the whole
thing would make a good tick tock video
it's not natural to think that way it
shouldn't be anyway
it's not surprising though when this
generation of parents my generation
views moments in life or really all of
life itself through this lens many of us
have been conditioned to put all of
ourselves out there for viewing making
spectacle of even the most banal moments
and experiences but not everything needs
to be presented to the public in this
manner and i say that as somebody whose
job necessitates talking into a camera
for over an hour every day
one of the reasons why we should retain
some semblance of a private life for
ourselves and especially for our
children is that the internet is not a
good substitute for a trusted confidant
or counselor
if you really feel that you need to vent
your frustrations or you need to a
shoulder to cry on or you need some
wisdom and guidance the comments section
of tick tock is by far and away the
absolute worst place to turn faceless
strangers who are scrolling social media
looking for content to distract them
from their own personal lives are not
suited for any of the roles i just
listed
they also don't know you or care about
you
and they will have forgotten about what
you posted five seconds after they see
it
the bigger problem is that when when you
when you get into the habit
of packaging your life into these
bite-sized videos and social media posts
and offering them up as pieces of
entertainment for strangers who will
then in return give you a rating through
likes and shares which you will
obsessively track and count
when you do all that and you do it every
day for years as so many people do
after a while you begin to lose the
ability to live your life as a normal
human being you forfeit your humanity to
a large extent
you begin to think about all of your
experiences in terms of how many likes
they can get you start engineering
things in your life so they'll be better
fodder for an influencer post
you live your life with your back turn
to it looking at it through your phone
with your face in the foreground and
everything else blurred into the
background
we now have multiple generations of
americans who live this way constantly
sacrificing authenticity
for the sake of making content
until they no longer know how to live
often
[Music]
so cat calamani is far from alone
but she is the one who is today
unfortunately cancelled
well before you go uh hit the subscribe
button and ring the bell and while
you're at it if you want to go watch or
listen to my full show head to
dailywire.com and subscribe you can also
catch my show on spotify apple podcast
or wherever you get your podcast so go
check it out now i demand it
your compliance is somewhat appreciated